-Three children, 8, 3 and then
one that´s very young, yeah?
-Yes, Eli is 1-years-Old.
-Congratulations on that.
-Yes.
I say I have two children
and a terrorist.
-Who´s the terrorist?
-The middle child, of course.
-The middle one´s the terrorist?
-Yes, yes.
-Oh, my God.
That´s interesting to know.
Do the -- so the 8 and 3 --
obviously one has no idea,
do the 8 and 3 year old have any
sense of what you do?
-The 8-year-old does, yes.
-Okay.
Impressed with it at all?
-I think she is, actually.
-Oh, that´s good.
-Yeah.
-Does she understand how hard it
is to do three-hundred episodes
of a television show?
-That, she definitely
doesn´t know.
-Yeah.
Not many people do.
-No.
And congratulations on that.
-Thank you.
-Did you have any --
At what point in
the run did you ever --
have comprehended
it could go on this long?
-Well, every year I keep saying
this is the last year,
they´re definitely going
to get sick of us.
The ratings are going to plummet
and we´re over at
the end of this year.
I say it every single year,
and it never happens.
I can´t believe people aren´t
sick of me yet.
-Well, I --
-[ Laughing ] It´s crazy.
-Not only am I not sick of you,
but, you know, you are sort of
the connective tissue --
Meredith Grey´s
connective tissue
of that entire show.
Like, what do you think it is
about the relationship
the audience has with
that character that they´re
still so engaged with her
fourteen seasons into it?
-I -- Maybe they´re
all drinking tequila.
and not really paying attention.
[ Laughter ]
-No, they´re paying attention.
-I don´t know, honestly!
I don´t know.
I think --
I hope that, you know,
as actors our goal is
to make people feel, right?
-Mm-hmm.
-And so, I think, you know,
I do my best to try
to make people feel something,
whether it´s sadness
or happiness or anger
or whatever it is.
And I do my best.
And we all do our best.
And it´s --
It´s actually, you know,
the journey of it has been
quite interesting
because obviously, we´ve had our
ups and downs behind the scenes.
And I loved that we´ve --
You know,
the journey as a whole.
It started out one way
and it´s ending --
Not that it´s ending,
but right now where we are
is such a different place
from where we started, you know?
It´s been a very
interesting journey.
-Well, I don´t think a show
could successfully succeed
for fourteen seasons
unless it did change.
-Yes.
-And was that something
that everybody understood?
Or were there people within
the production that thought,
"Oh, no, we can never change
this, got to stay this forever."
Or was everybody sort of open to
the idea of letting it evolve?
-No, no one´s open
to letting it evolve.
I think that, you know,
everybody was devastated
when Patrick Dempsey left.
-Uh-huh.
-And I think that, you know,
the network especially thought,
you know, the show was never
going to make it.
And they rushed in
a new love interest,
like, thirty seconds later.
[ Laughter ]
Because I --
I could never carry the show.
Let´s not get crazy.
Oh, no, I think you could.
-I think Grey
could carry the show.
But, no, it´s --
I think that now people
understand that the evolution
is part of why it sustains.
But I think that the idea of
something so successful changing
is frightening to people.
I think change is
frightening to people.
-Your relationship with the show
has changed as well because now
you´re not only
an actor on the show,
but you´ve also
directed episodes.
How is it to see, you know,
a product you´ve been a part of
from one perspective
for so long,
how crazy is it to look at it
from a different side
of the camera?
-I mean, I really think every
actor should direct,
because it is
a completely different
viewpoint, you know?
But again, I´m super blessed
because I -- You know,
Shonda Rhimes has allowed me
to evolve with the show
and direct
and help produce the show.
So, now I have more ownership
over the show and much more
of a say.
Did you ever see that --
The documentary about Bob Evans?
Yeah.
-The kid stays in the picture
when he says, the --
He says, "I want to be that guy,
the producer,
´cause I can´t get fired."
-Yeah.
-You know?
And I -- That always stuck
with me and I always saw that
-- You know, you got to own it
and be a part of it
´cause actors are sort of
the highest paid
on the totem pole, but
the lowest in terms of power.
-Right. They never kill off
the producer.
-Yeah, they never kill off
So, to have --
actually be a woman
in the television business
and have power over my situation
and for Shonda to sort of see me
as a partner instead of just
an employee is something I think
we´re both very proud of.
-And I think that speaks
to how women in power lead
to more women in power
in any industries,
so it´s really nice
to have Shonda there
and it´s really nice
to have you here.
And congratulations on 300
episodes, what a pleasure.